as the number of chronovirus infections
rise mayor bill de blasio putting
new york city into a state of emergency
in light of all those changing realities
it is time now to declare a state of
emergency in new york city
where over 500 people would gather
parades rallies concerts sports events
professional conferences etc we'll now
no longer have gatherings and i
unfortunately suspect that will be a
number of months
my next guest led new york city through
its last great crisis
september 11th rudy giuliani former new
york city mayor joins me now rudy great
to see you
is de blasio um you know a second guest
people it's a complex series of
decisions you have to make
weighing public safety versus freedom
and the economy and business
uh but he said months is that the right
move well first of all
on declaring a state of emergency i
wouldn't second guess him i am
i actually am surprised that he hasn't
been around for months
i mean the the the president is
criticized unfairly
he was involved in this in december de
blasio was
i guess sleeping which is what he
usually does uh the governor i actually
wrote a note in a tweet praising the
governor for getting on top of this
four or five weeks ago i didn't see de
blasio at all when we had west nile
virus in new york city i held a press
conference the next day
on a saturday and held a press
conference every single day until he got
control
of west nile virus the governor didn't
have to come in and take over
this guy's like four or five weeks late
now is he right
about a state of emergency he has the
statistics i will not second guess about
him
to save months is a terrible mistake
first of all he doesn't know it's going
to be months
so i always believed that you tell
people the truth
and then you leave them during during a
crisis with a sense of hope
so on september 11 the worst day in the
history of the city now i've finished it
by saying that then people in new york
are going to come out of this and
they're going to come out of it stronger
that's after i honestly described to
them how devastating everything was
and that that isn't a leader that's a
guy
first of all way too late i mean he's
he's running for the fire and the fire
has already
destroyed half the building and
everybody else has been there and he
wants to get on it
and then just a simple mistake like that
for many months
now it may be many months it may be
a few weeks a state of emergency is a
very very very
serious thing to do well and rudy i
think i think one of our friends over at
fbn
said this yesterday you you do have to
you do have to think long term while you
deal with a short-term problem you can't
just
completely throw out the window the
long-term implications
of the precedent that we are setting in
the united states every time a pathogen
escapes from a foreign country and and
comes
especially like china it's not our
necessarily our great friend
uh that everything is going to shut down
in the united states i mean
that's a that it's a weapon that becomes
a weapon in and of itself
to someone with bad motives that's what
i'm concerned about it's one of the
reasons why i tried very hard to get new
york city awake again right after
september 11.
you better i wanted to say to the
terrorists hey you can't come here and
we can take some risk we're we're tough
we're tough people you're not going to
ruin our economy
uh actually there was just a beautiful
article in the daily news by christine
nicholas
pointing out that i got broadway back
two weeks faster than they wanted to
and i got him back for a very specific
purpose they weren't making any money
nobody was coming
but they were performing every night and
eventually they all came back
yes they have leadership requires
giving people a balance you got to give
them what they need to be safe
but you also have to give them what they
need to be realistic and hopeful
de blasio blew it in two ways first of
all he's too late nobody's going to
listen to it
we made that point all right okay and
number two i know i made it but i just
made it one more time sorry i know but
it's cable tv rudy you're not on my old
radio show you can talk for an hour all
right you gotta
we got but but rudy they're saying that
this is worse than 9 11. people like joe
scarborough
people are saying like john meacham the
esteemed biographer
i've always liked john meacham but now
he's saying he's speculating that this
could lead to a depression
well how does he know that exactly this
is what's sending people to the grocery
store to buy
a hundred a hundred pallets of water
there's no way to know whether it's
going to lead to a depression
whether in some ways they're going to be
conflicting things that actually help
the economy in the money that's put into
health care and everything else
a lot of people overestimated 9 11. i
did i over
estimated the estimate the estimate that
i made of losses was three times what it
turned out to be
because i didn't consider all of the
relief work that was going to be done
that pumped up the economy and created
jobs in other areas so
these are predictions that these are
predictions that are made from
political bias yeah they're not made
from intelligent thinking they're made
from we need transparency
and facts and hope and sometimes every
now and then some humor
i think we need that too and prayers
yeah rudy thank you so much it's great
to have you on tonight and great to see
you tonight
thank you